guys I love you and I want to see you
and if you're watching this I hope that
you love me too I tore the world doing
stand-up comedy and if you've seen me
you've had a good time I know that and
if you haven't seen me come see me and
have a good time all my tour dates are
up right now and I start touring very
soon again October 14th and 15th for the
first time ever I'm up in Canada I've
been asked to come to Canada for like
seven years and I have not been there
I'm playing Hamilton and Toronto Toronto
has actually showed up so much that we
added a second show
um Richmond Virginia and Hershey
Pennsylvania October 28th and 29th
Hershey Pennsylvania we we're sold out
and we had to add a second show Richmond
Virginia I've never been there Gara was
just there he had a great time he told
me he was going to plug my shows in
Richmond while he was on stage I don't
know if he did if you saw him write to
me and let me know if he lied to me but
I will excited about Richmond now we're
moving on to November in November I have
a banging weekend on the 11th 12th and
13th I am in Knoxville can't wait to
come to Knoxville I did Nashville and I
did um uh what's the other place in in
Tennessee that I did not Memphis uh
Knoxville Tennessee you guys always come
out hard I'm so excited to go to
Knoxville
um Atlanta my first time Solo in Atlanta
I'm so excited we added a second show in
Atlanta Atlanta and Phoenix are the two
places that I get requested the most
Atlanta I heard you I'm coming we added
the show at the center Stage Theater on
November 12th November 13th I'm in
Birmingham Alabama also a first time I
love Birmingham my boy Roy Wood Jr reps
Birmingham and I can't wait to come down
there at the at the Alabama Theater
November 18th and 19th these are shows
that were postponed from the pandemic
and I cannot wait to get to Louisville
and I keep being told I'm pronouncing
that wrong Louisville Louisville
um I'm so excited to go to Louisville uh
on uh the 18th of November at the brown
theater and then the Evans uh and
Evansville Indiana home of Don Mattingly
Victory theater on November 19th
and I round off December in Florida and
California and I hope you come uh
December big weekend in Florida December
2nd 3rd and 4th uh at Jacksonville
Jacksonville Jacksonville never been
there excited I'm playing the Florida
theater if you know someone in
Jacksonville Florida let them know Tampa
we're adding a second show
December 3rd at the Tampa Theater Tampa
comes out huge adding a second show
there thank you and then Orlando Florida
hard rock live in Orlando is going to be
a banger Orlando's fun the Hard Rock's
fun I'm fun that's a triple whammy
December 16. this is my last tour dates
of the year in uh
Northern California Sacramento
uh on December 16th at the Crest theater
uh San Jose which I'm by the way San
Jose shout out to my boy my boy my gal
whatever you wanna my girl Bailey
um my buddy Pam who is from San Jose
represents I have family in San Jose I
can't wait to see them at the San Jose
Civic Theater on December 17th and Santa
Rosa California never been there in my
life so excited on December 18th look if
you didn't want to hear all those dates
you could have skipped it but I'd rather
I'd rather talk to you conversationally
and tell you my feelings instead of
always just being like I'm here I'm here
I'm here I'm here I'm here I'm here so
that's why we extended this one if you
don't like it you could just hit the
skip button but if you do I appreciate
you listening tell a friend that I'm
coming to this city uh and stay in
school pass on grass
generousinfo.com for your show
information ticket links all that stuff
coming up next October we got dead crow
comedy club in North Carolina
in November I'll be going to Michigan do
a bunch of shows and I've got tons of
other stuff around that stuff and after
that stuff and coming up in the new year
and all that anyway you can find all of
it at jodarosainfo.com also if you're in
New York City please come to my bar and
sandwich shop Joey roses uh all info for
there is Joey
rose'snyc.com we're open six days a week
opening at 12 P.M every day great
sandwiches awesome hang and lots of
booze taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste bud here we go hey folks
it's
t-a-s-t-e Buds where the buds are back
baby
yeah you're in a couple a week without
me possibly two weeks but we might not
have that we might have lost that that
one who did you want to lose you in soda
we might have lost this me and soda soda
if you're watching and we know that we
did it there's a good shot we didn't
okay hopefully we did it was a hot
episode it's coming up it's casseroles
versus salads salads so broad I always
thought he was garbage he's garbage dude
he's a kid yeah you too I mean he but
he's self-admitted right oh no he
Embraces it yes and aren't you
well you should hear the way he talks
about casseroles it was it's disturbing
yeah it's disturbing does he have an
affinity for them or he was against them
an affinity and he actually thinks that
they're like a a like a an actual like
food group that's all I need to know
can I can I say something I don't I
don't remember not only the last time I
ever had a casserole Thanksgiving I
don't know if I've had a casserole and
I've never cooked a casserole oh no oh
green beans yeah what's that
Thanksgiving green bean casserole a
little Dominique up top yeah no that's
that's string beans almondine well you
do string beans different the
casserole's got the it's got the juices
it's wetter what is what is what
constitutes a casserole uh gross it's
all
you put food in a day I mean I mean he's
he's a Box Meal hobo like he like
he's a fox
[Laughter]
oh jukebox Heroes
and he doesn't get a Lunchables uh thing
to jukebox Heroes
we should have someone re-record it and
he send it to soda by the way Joe gotta
welcome to
so here we go the term Castro can refer
to any dish prepared in a casserole dish
that's it essentially a deep wide baking
dish and baked in the oven a castle can
have layers as uh in the case of an
Italian lasagna lasagna is a casserole
it is basically yeah
stand on that leg that's what you got
okay deep dish pizza is a casserole
though they're playing fast food stop
yeah no I I said that lasagna is the one
acceptable meal casserole and then I
also said green bean casserole at
Thanksgiving is amazing yeah I didn't
realize lasagna was that a pop I falls
into casserole as well then
yeah of Reggie approaching the starch in
a bowl basically yeah it seems like
I don't remember I don't remember I
don't feel like people like here I made
casserole tonight maybe I've had cash in
the 1950s in the 50s right 50s I'll come
over my wife then last night my wife
very mad men for sure Superman very mad
men very mad men he was deep throating
[ __ ] casseroles all the time
remember the season finale is three was
how many castles could he eat that's
right and then they got the big they
lost a big account of Delta
I mean it's it's it's a food that it's
it what was that casserole he defended
turkey what was it turkey dude he first
of all he went hard on tuna casserole
It's upsetting It's upsetting what's in
a tuna casserole tuna is the main dish
but what else some kind of creamy
creaminess yeah I know it did it's it's
look at that dude look at that no come
10 horse rated casseroles in the world
that looks like what oh that looks like
my dog threw up that's exactly what that
looks like that does look like vomit of
a dog it looks like a sponge cake hold
on what are the by the way for the
viewers at home I got my fingers wrapped
because I cut it coming into the
building on the door today that's why I
have the thing on my face what is the
white stuff that's not egg what are
those white things is that a water oh
are you kidding me a joke I was gonna
say a water chest oh my God
do not go too fast let's go back to the
bundt cake that looks like it literally
looks like you took you swiped at
anything you could grab yeah and just
molded it yeah like a garbage plate
casserole yeah it looks like it looks
like oh my God I don't know a hearts of
palm should never live in a casserole
also like we're getting a little cute
with the bunt ring no just that doesn't
count as a casserole that's a bun make
it in a thing cut a square that
literally is what defines a casserole is
a casserole dish yeah that's not a
casserole they probably popped it out of
the dish maybe that no because it was
made in a bundt cake dish that's not a
casserole all right well we need to
write a Stern letter to this website
technically that's what is this
yeah
braised no chives that are rolled in ham
mer oh it's just ends traditionally
that's not a casserole yeah this is this
is this is not a good website that
you've done here that's a that's a [ __ ]
ing throw right there right what is that
hot dish
hot dish it's such a good term for
taking a dump it's never a good sign
when the casserole when the casserole
just has a name yeah that has nothing to
do with the food and it's famous to
being from North Dakota yeah no that's
that's that's that's when you're ashamed
to tell anybody what's in it yeah is
that what you mean God look at that dude
I'm gonna barf I'm gonna bar Tetrazzini
that's one of my dog's names
this may be a case of Joe has 18 18 dogs
and they're only he has 26. 26. I
haven't seen you in a minute
come on bro yeah Joe has gone from well
naturally from one dog to 26 but you you
had like six for a while maybe eight
yeah that works you cracked like 12 but
you were hovering there then I remember
you hit 18 and we were like should we
talk to him
and then now you know he has 26. 26 yeah
and they're all named after pastries and
Italian dishes yeah we had to expand I'm
gonna name the next one hot dish
[Laughter]
the dogs when they're on their way out
yeah yeah no actually I knew that about
you that's a really nice thing that you
do I like to have a morbid home
that you could devote your time to we do
a podcast about pretzels
yeah that's very that's that's amazing
all the local hospitals know when
they're in the middle of a defib with
the dogs they call Joe they're like
we're going to bring them back to life
you want to take them I'm like let me
let me listen in the background
like too much
that's what I wanted Joe just brings
them home lays them down and then just
that afternoon he swatches and pants
I'm look at me here's a pillow all right
let's go 26 dogs all stuffed yeah I I
wanted to I wanted to my nephew was
really scared of one of my dogs and I
wanted to for Christmas it died by
Christmas I really wanted to get it
stuffed and wrap it and give it to him
that'll be phenomenal wouldn't that be
great oh they wouldn't let me do it oh
who's they my sister Carla told me oh
and she's like you'll torture him and I
was like it's he was 16. no but honestly
that is the funniest thing I think that
would be like of Legends yeah but will
they stuff a dog ah probably do people
stuffed taxidermist don't you feel like
you'd hear more like people being like I
didn't want to let them go I stuffed my
dog
I think you would I don't hear that I'm
sure people do it I mean people a
thousand percent do it I've never met
anybody nobody in Austin Q's looking
into cloning this cat I think correct
shut up I think he is shut up
found that thing in a can
they found that Hot Fish
he doesn't want it to become a hot dish
ingredient
um no I no but he he's a I mean that cat
the one the Benjamin is like if like I
don't know I that's like the most
important things here in the world yeah
Benjamin's my biscotti yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
well who's my daughter my first rescue
dog
that's messed up because isn't your
first dog not biscotti yes my second dog
your first dog is cannoli cannoli but
cannoli was bought she's a diva she's
got an attitude yeah I'm gonna take a
ship of whiskey here yeah because I'm
hitting here because I couldn't because
because
we're in the apartment you want to talk
about a [ __ ] pig lineage this place
was
passed down to Chris to step it out I
didn't realize it's a animal farm this
place there's no classes yeah there's no
glasses here I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
burn this outfit by sitting on this
couch and I walked into this and I
thought it was a hostel
this place is well there's nothing here
an atrocity look at this couch this is a
couch that was bought by a millionaire
this is a very expensive couch there is
no way I promise you that there's no way
it's expensive super expensive couches
don't come in this color okay I just
don't they just don't I'll tell you
right now I have hang on about how much
this couch is you want to take a guess
1500 Max Max are you were you born in
the United States of America yeah you
should stand up I can understand it's an
Ikea couch this is this is a cloud couch
from restoration hallway this couch is
twenty thousand dollars
fifteen hundred dollars
this is the casserole of couches
it's it's made of all down it's called
the cloud cache I'll tell you something
right now though it some versions are
better than others because this couch is
very very uncomfortable to me yeah
really you've made a weird pillow fort
in the corner as well if you don't it's
the depth is off and then you sink in it
gets all like weird but I am it's great
in theory everyone always says I have
one of these yeah upstairs it's the one
upstairs right like in the second floor
of the of the of the apartment it's the
one we sit on for the podcast no no in
the other room okay okay but it's it's a
smaller version but it's a different I
don't know dude we're really talking
about this Castle all right I do want to
know the fact that you think is the 1500
is the funniest thing I've ever heard
this is a couch to me what this is down
in here this is you know how many goose
died for this this is like this is like
Ontario my head what couch has it I mean
I don't mean with them I mean with
anybody who has it if you have a couch
and you're dating somebody you've banged
on your couch
so so let's talk let's let's talk trash
for a second the guy who's a kid the guy
who's holding an open bottle of Jack and
actively bleeding wants to talk trash on
me
you're a crime scene right now you look
like you look like an extra
of like a Law and Order SVU like 16 you
have the sack to call soda hobo you're
literally you're an electric hero hot
trash hero
that's Santino today goes he goes why
do does he like Staten Island he was so
perplexed by him Andrew said theater
today who Sandra Santino no what is who
like it you I know I go drive it up
that's that island that to record with
sound he goes
I go why
doesn't know what nice things are
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't know what nice things are splice
that with him criticizing me for only
liking nice things please slice that
first of all I'm hungover because
Santino Santino's where why isn't he on
today last night he said he was gonna
meet me at my bar I didn't want to go to
the bar I didn't want to go but I
literally went because I go I told
Santino I'd meet him there no show no
show he no shows and then I get Nicole
no show no call no show texting me goes
I just woke up I got to do a spot after
I was already there for an hour oh so I
ended up hanging out and got pretty
tanked up it's my fault but he he no
called no show and then um so then today
I'm talking to him and he I go I go the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] balls on this
[ __ ] ginzo over here
half Hispanic
the better I made mention of that in the
phone call I won't get into it
I go just try on a text right yesterday
goes goes oh [ __ ] Bobby and Santina were
out in Staten Island doing Christmas
podcast the other day
uh it's gonna be tough to get them to
come back out to Staten Island it's a
shame I go this
I've been driving out here weekly for a
year he has never once expressed
sympathy for it but Andrew said you know
Bobby's like oh I hate to ask these guys
to come out again I hate to ask him I
didn't think they would do it I think
it's out of the way for them they're
here for a finite amount of time
you're here for a finite amount of time
doing multiple podcasts and the Hub is
the city they have spots I don't think
they take two treks out here being that
they're on this being our home and being
our home base and a studio for us I
don't think it's that bad I come to the
city I come to roses
it took me two hours it took me two
hours and 15 minutes to get here today
not that anyone cares the rest it took
me two hours and 15 minutes to get here
from Northern Long Island I came from uh
Memphis Tennessee
it came from I came from Long Island
what are you doing I'm out there why are
you living on Long Island you're telling
me things that I already know
you're saying words that I already hear
in my head I don't
know
It's the funniest joke that's ever been
told in 100 episodes yeah and there's
one person on this couch if you just put
this on mute you said who are you gonna
take advice from on this couch give me
that give me that right now he's leading
from his hand he's like you guys need to
listen to me you don't know how to live
your life let me tell you who's got it
figured out
Cheers Cheers Jack
you're in Manhattan last night getting
stood up by a friend for one hour at
your own establishments oh my God that
redheaded what is he is he Italian
Santino or is he like Louis C.K where
he's Mexican I think he has like a a
little bit of a mix in there right I
think he might be
Italian Irish for sure but I thought
also maybe that's it maybe that's it I
don't know no I mean I wish we would
have known when they were here we would
have doubled up next time we'll try to
double up with them well so Bobby's
never been on anything either Bobby Lake
yeah yeah but neither is no no I don't
mean this I still have I still haven't
been I still haven't been he's talking
about guess you rather
yeah so I'll just go [ __ ] yourself
thanks for having me
I greatly appreciate you making the trip
for this today especially given the fact
that I would never drive to Long Island
to do your podcast thank you thank you
and I'm filming the city for that reason
I can't get Steve to come out to Long
Island I would be like can we Zoom
we'll work with the delay
so plug your podcast you got a pocket We
Love Steve Byrne he's about my best
friends in the world oh he really
doesn't care for you
that's all that you'd say that I was
just I'm in this house in uh uh uh
Nashville yup I went to visit him I was
I was on a road trip and I passed
through
it uh sticks out nicer guy Steve is
Steve was like I was like this house is
beautiful and he goes yeah dude it's
great it's great it's great um you know
we bought it for this bunch and he goes
it's appreciated to this he's like you
know it's a good thing
but Steve's so nice that he immediately
he goes and that will drop that'll drop
and I was like do it it's okay
yeah it was happening to me as you're
bleeding all over his couch and dragging
your bottle of whiskey behind you I'm
sitting in his 500 000 kitchen and he's
going can you hook me up with your web
guy I go I'm living in a [ __ ] one
bedroom you [ __ ] animal what the [ __ ]
and you and you you turn your nose at my
three bedroom four bed
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you take off his mattress it's a bathtub
under it it's a converted tub
all right so so so I think Marshmallow
is overrated
so the argument the battle today it's
time for
oh no no no but let's we're not let's
announce what the battle is okay before
but yes yeah sure it's marshmallows
versus by the way it's marshmallows it's
not marshmallows that's what mallow more
that's why it's spelled Malamar not
Malamar okay interesting bro so we're
doing marshmallows versus caramel
yeah which is interesting
because both are
food is a strong they're both confection
they can be had alone as in a caramel
Cube or marshmallow they could be had in
other forms such as liquid they could be
drizzled on ice cream they could be had
in sandwiches and other things and
they're both fondues flavors like like
you'll get a marshmallow
coffee or or caramel flavored coffee or
whatever yeah I've never had a
marshmallow coffee there's like
marshmallow flavored somethings like I
feel like well you know what I'm
thinking of like hot chocolate yeah
s'mores are rocky road they both show up
in ice creams you gotta you know uh
right dolce de leche and you've got a
rocky road you're right that's true and
if you ever got real fancy and you have
a brain on yourself you made a s'mores
you might have drizzled some caramel on
there they go together too caramel and
marshmallows can go together so here's
but here's toppings yes yes here's
what's yes liquidy or ice cream toppings
and many marshmallows they both come in
minis you have the mini caramel chips
yes right I will say marshmallows make
an appearance in cereals
caramel probably does too actually it's
a good matchup it's good yeah I don't
know though who in the god forsaken
world doesn't like caramel well I think
as a general
sense of practice there are people that
are divided on marshmallows that's
what's interesting about today's battle
if I may is sogato's here God is Not
Gonna battle he's gonna moderate which
we do sometimes but he hates
and we we're doing this again with with
some with I don't want to ruin it but we
got another episode coming up where
we're going to do this with a guest
but uh gato today is going to moderate
oh you don't like caramel I don't like
either Oh I thought it was me and you
versus him for a second there oh how do
you not you both don't like caramel
I like caramel but I'm team marshmallow
oh it's caramel I don't think caramels
uh marshmallows good I don't know that's
[ __ ] you do because and here's why
in this morning this is another thing
that's interesting we've I've argued
against Marshmallow in the s'more battle
because I do think s'mores suck yeah
um that's crazy but that's a
construction thing more than anything
marshmallow Okay I don't like I don't
like a lot of it beginning with just at
face value let's take the marshmallow
Standalone as it's supposed to be all
right let's let's start the battle ready
sure oh all right no chance today let's
just do it ready yeah unless you want to
do a chain no all right ready yes okay
time four
b-a-t-t-l buds wait what sorry I forgot
sorry ready did you just I forgot yeah I
spelled it wrong sure leave me alone all
right ready here we go
you spelled it wrong how many times have
you spelled it
how many times spelled it get your [ __ ]
together spelled s p e l t like tuna
spelled yes get up here like a tuna melt
listen keep up guys I'll slow it down
for everybody spelled the word spelled
yeah spelled spelled all right all right
here we go ready ready I'm ready
[Laughter]
buds all right
the chance of great you need chance it
gets everybody fired up you know what's
happening now it takes me a minute to
spell it out to make sure so you're
battling now is that what happens yes
you could just say let's battle or
anything but you want to spell it out I
might get for the dramatic effect don't
let me interrupt don't sorry I mean it's
been a few weeks since you guys have
gotten salty
it's been quite a few weeks oh I already
insulted him for the first half hour I
got salty shrimp today we already
insulted each other we showed Joe we
already insulted each other for like
wait you don't think I know you don't
think I know how salty this guy I mean
seriously he's literally the the human
version of Oscar the Grouch minus the
garbage can like he's walking around he
puts jeans on instead of a garbage can
even wears gold which can't call it Big
pants for people so he can blend in he's
the Dead Sea personified that's how
salty he is
uh yeah sometimes we do a channel we say
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty to amp up
the battle Yeah and then at the end of
it we immediately insult one another oh
okay but we also that came later what
came first is after we were fighting so
much he was like I'm taking this home
with me and I don't like it so the first
chance we did was no matter what happens
I love you three times ah and then we do
the battle then we found out that it was
like softening the battles okay but
so so this really bothers you when you
talk about Foods on a couch and people
watch it on the internet this is this
weighs heavy on you well we probably had
something okay well you really should
just take it down enough because the
world has real problems that I can list
right now instead of bigger that if a
marshmallow I gotta tell you though the
show would have been a flop otherwise
yeah people are like I can't believe you
guys get this man about Tostitos oh yeah
you know what I mean
so that's what makes it work
guys if you are like me then in the
summer you are hot and when you go to
bed you're hot I have actually a memory
foam mattress that retains heat I run
hot and a lot of times if it's too warm
I sweat through the night I hate it I
have to change my sheets the next day or
if I crank up the AC too much and it's
so cold that I'm buried under the
blankets I sweat anyway so Miracle brand
is this new sponsor of the podcast that
do sheets that are self-cooling bed
sheets uh and you can stay comfortable
all night long it uses silver infused
Fabrics made by NASA uh to be
temperature regulated bedding uh so you
can sleep at the perfect temperature all
night long this is something that you
probably know but maybe you don't think
about it but and this is a crazy fact
bed sheets can Harbor more bacteria than
a toilet seat they can lead to acne
allergies and stuff he knows this is
gross actually uh Miracle ran offers a
whole line of self-cleaning eco-friendly
bedding such as sheets pillowcases
comforters that prevent 99 of bacteria
and require to be laundered three times
less I just got my set in the mail I'm
loving them instantly uh the first night
I felt the difference literally felt
cooler the entire night they have
self-cooling properties like I mentioned
uh they're self-cleaning
this is crazy this is like a sheet this
is like the revolution not a revolution
revolutionizing the sheet industry
they're comfortable they're quality and
they're better for your skin go to try
miracle.com taste buds to try today
we've got a special deal for our
listeners booze be sure to use our promo
code taste buds at checkout to save 40
for zero percent and get three free
towels who doesn't love a bacteria free
towel and Miracle is so confident their
product it's back with a 30 day money
back guarantee if you aren't a hundred
percent satisfied full refund
upgrade to sleep with Miracle brand go
to try miracle.com tastebuds and use the
code taste buds to claim your free
three-piece towel set and save 40 off
again that's try miracle.com taste buds
thank you to miraclebrand for sponsoring
the episode
all right guys we are so happy to have
Factor back as a sponsor of the podcast
I actually legitimately use Factor
um I'm ordering today I'm ordering more
factor I originally got my first order
from them because we're trying it out
because they send it to you for the
podcast and they got me hooked
um you know for me I have a pack
schedule and I don't cook and factor out
well unless I'm you know unless I'm
choosing to cook for the most part I'd
rather not
um so they have ready to eat meal
delivery okay and the stuff is good in
the past I've tried meal deliveries over
the past the few years and I tried ones
that were really really well rated and I
thought they were okay at best the first
time I got fact there I enjoyed every
single thing they sent it was delicious
it was filling and it actually tasted
good and it was like meals and recipes
that I was like oh man this is I
actually like that
um and I even get smoothies from these
strawberry banana smoothies are low in
sugar I start my day off with them and
then when I get home from work I
literally just take one I look I have
like six seven things readily made I
take one I throw it in I heat it up and
it tastes good that's what I want to say
is that it actually tastes good it's
cheaper than takeout uh thanks to their
commitment to ingredients with Integrity
you can actually feel good about what
you're eating every day it's healthy
stuff not only just Factor off a fast
simple
Solutions when you know you need the
most they also help you stay on top of
goals when it's hard to carve out time
offering so you they have they when you
when you order you can order specified
kits you could do Protein Plus or keto
things like that they have calorie smart
options vegan and veggie options keto
protein so you can choose the type of
like goals that you're looking for I
choose veggie or Protein Plus
um
they get they're Chef crafted they're
dietitian approved
um and so that's the difference between
them it's and and people that send
Frozen things or or the like in fact
there is everything I need for a good
week of eats in addition to readily made
meals they have cold pressed juices and
smoothies energy bites extra protein
veggie sides I I love Factor head to go
dot
factor75.com
tastebuds 130. this is the one thing I
remember about factor is it is a bit of
a mouthful but it is worth it and then
you get a bit of a mouthful see what I
did had to go dot factor75.com the
number 75.com
tastebuds130 and use code tastebuds130
to get one hundred and thirty dollars
off across six boxes let me repeat that
one more time it's code taste buds one
three zero at gogeo dot
factor75.com slash tastebuds130
I need to get 130 off if you've been
thinking of trying one of these at all
try this one I think that you will like
it guys you asked for it for so long we
finally got it merch is on sale right
now uh we really talk about it but I
want to start pushing it because we have
a really cool designs that Joe and I
made up ourselves and it's the limited
run so whatever is on sale now the
second is sold out it's not coming back
it's available right now uh in the links
on these videos or at our website
savocanocomedy.com Joe derosainfo.com
that's tastebuds merch I also have solo
merch uh up there as well uh and uh so
check all of it out and uh and and buy
some merch tweeted us the merch and we
will retweet you we'll repost you on
Instagram we want to see which ones you
guys are liking and we want to see the
merch out in the wild really cool
project that we put together sort of see
it out there is going to be cool so
check out our March for perch anyway so
I like caramel I was just thinking about
I like caramel in three forms I like it
on a s'mores I like it on a s'more well
that you're putting you're putting it on
a s'mores it's not a traditional small
yeah you can't stall like that I mean I
like you know I like I like peanut
butter marshmallow is you said I like
caramel on a sport you mean marshmallow
I'm sorry did I say camera you said
caramel so I meant marshmallow it's okay
sorry about that wow yes okay wow bat
yeah let's start it over there you go my
mind's playing tricks on me okay so I
like it on a s'more I like big money I
drive big cars everybody know me it's
like I'm a movie star all right I like
it uh in certain cereals like a lucky
charm okay and I like it um
a mini one to shoot out of a an air gun
to shoot out of an air gun yeah you ever
see those marshmallow squares the mini
ones
I've never encountered one in real life
you should it's fun it's a lot loads of
fun yeah they they actually replace like
Nerf bullets with marshmallow guns where
you were able to shoot confection
Confections at your friends yes okay
that's fun honestly take a regular
mushroom I'll put it in your mouth I
don't see the appeal I don't think it's
fun I think it's like it feels weird it
feels like you're eating something with
a consistency that just shouldn't be a
food and then when you bite into it and
you had to break it down and it starts
getting like uber sticky the taste of a
marshmallow stand alone maybe it'll
complement things like chocolate but the
taste Standalone is also completely
underwhelming it's nothing great and do
you ever rip one apart or like bite it
in pieces I can't stand how sticky you
might as well the only thing worse to
get on you or your clothes is like egg
roll out is is caramel what are you
talking about you're talking about the
the most sticky worst thing you get on
your
caramel is the worst worst of all time
ever you get when if you bite into I'm
trying to think of caramel cube is like
you know if you're trying if you're
trying to think about like uh like even
like in a Snickers the caramel layer
Carmelo
is it Carmelo it's like the little
little squares
Carmelo is the same he's coming through
immediately did you just quote Another
Bad Creation ABC BBD the whole yes
son that I get hurt you fight a [ __ ]
Rolo you bite a Rolo sorry for the F's
for no reason but you buy the Rolo that
immediately drips on you it's so now I
will say this I will say this I will go
through an entire box of what's the
yellow candies
the the yellow box with the uh Malinois
Artisan writing on it no like when you
give somebody a box of cake Whitman
sampler is that what it is
the Artisan writing it has yeah
like an artist it looks like it's
crochet because you know what he meant
it was the right word yeah see it looks
yeah it looks like it's artisanal yeah
there you go thank you I mean there's an
artisanal or Artisan artisanal is
something something done by an artisan
artisanal okay same thing same
difference okay great uh
Whitman's I'll go through just learn
that
no I didn't know if artisanal and
Artisan a plumber a plumber is something
that's someone who's plums
don't talk down to me I'm not I'm just
I'm trying my hardest you couldn't spell
battle 13 minutes ago you you put by the
way you Whitman's Whitman sampler is the
casserole the Box chocolate just so you
know you don't even know God bless I
love you I have an eight pound box
upstairs and somebody got me as a gay
gift but it goes like you know you get
your top tier chocolates and in in Mass
marketplaces you're doing something like
a Godiva then you're going to a Russell
Stover's and Whitman's don't forget
about Ferrara Rocher oh yeah okay yes
but Godiva doesn't do a sampler box
yeah they do really the big four there
really yeah foreign
Russell Stover and then we should have
done a Russell versus Whitman with you
guys let's talk about other other topics
you want to do with other guests while
on my episode that would be so fun for
me my point is this is this is demands
all over the back
this is my point I will go through an
entire box of Whitman's looking for the
one caramel okay oh that's the one that
makes me Shut the Box the Whitman's the
Whitman's any other flavor in the
Whitman's is a disgrace especially the
one with the pink [ __ ] in the middle and
that's not just a shot at Women's that's
everything Russell does that everybody
that's pink the orange I think that
might be marshmallow base it is
marshmallow based cream I think it's a
marshmallow base
it's a strawberry cream it's a
strawberry flavored marshmallow base
talking to me about my blood sugar type
is Stova
my blood type is ostova listen yeah it's
a marshmallow Google that [ __ ] go ahead
I dare you no it's a cream wait wait
wait hold on a second hold on a second
couple other things back it up one
second
wait let me finish my point go I will go
through the entire Whitman's box to find
that caramel but that caramel you bite
it it drips it is the worst thing you
can get in your clothing how dare you
say that marshmallows are messy they're
they're marshmallows are anything but
messy they don't they they stay
congealed when the inside gets wet
though in your mouth you get a wet you
get a must you get it you could have you
could have caramel in a non-liquid form
I'm gonna caramel as a all right that's
a filling that's the only way you mostly
get it but Snickers whatever it it it it
it pulls it whatever ultimately I'm
basing this battle on the taste of
caramel which I believe is truly
undeniable versus Marshmallow but let me
just
you realize that you realize that the
caramel
you realize that the caramel chocolate
in a Whitman's or any other boxes is the
same size shape and placement in every
box no matter what it's it's that's you
you can identify the caramel every time
after you have it the first time so the
fact that you're running through a box
to find the couch there's also a code oh
[ __ ] it's also I started making it's
also a legend no that's [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] and yes I will bring up
McDonald's in this episode oh no [ __ ]
just like how there was 100 episodes
when all the boot shaped McNuggets were
the dark meat and then they started
mixing dark and white meats and then all
of a sudden you were getting boot shaped
white Meats they did the same thing with
caramels in Russell Stover's box
you're defining a nugget is chicken I
can't even wrap my mind around the words
coming out of your mouth oh you don't
know oh listen to me no no I don't like
a chicken nugget it's not chicken it
doesn't matter
he wishes he worked at McDonald's he
wishes Ronald McDonald adopts him he
what he he he McDonald's is his Heaven
he's brought up McDonald's for this is
like the 97th episode he's brought up
McDonald's in all 97. he's somehow
finding a way to compare McNuggets to
the Battle of caramel and marshmallow I
thought that he was going to go with
that caramel is so popular that they
actually had to introduce that as the
second Hot Topic to the classic Sunday
they only had hot fudge
I know I'm not surprised is what I'm
saying what I'm saying is that would be
the way to use McDonald's in this
episode that's very that's very
interesting caramel was introduced in
1989 is a topping caramel what is the
second most popular topic for ice cream
and I will tell you McDonald's it's a
[ __ ] topping on ice cream when I have
ice cream that is a caramel infusion or
a topping on it
you're a [ __ ] for you to say that
caramel a topping on ice cream is not
good is so crazy it's undeniable a hot
caramel mixed with a cold vanilla ice
cream oh take a walk Go Tell it to the
[ __ ] marshmallow what are you doing
marshmallow what are you doing with
marshmallow what am I doing with
marshmallow about marshmallows what am I
doing marshmallow I'm kicking up every
cereal you have ever eaten in your life
that's the cereal with it no but it
doesn't matter you want to talk ice
cream we're going to talk cereal also
doesn't
you know that they hit that milk and
they are and that's the [ __ ] beauty
of them they have a dehydrated
marshmallow and when it hits that milk
it expands and becomes magnificent how
dare you you're gonna hang your whole
argument on cereal based marshmallows
you're gonna hang yours on ice cream no
no what else you got with care about
camel it's purest film a form I love
unwrapping that little clear wrapper and
having this cute cubes that feels really
good people talking about candy sucks
all people love them what
that are stupid it's all people and
young people there you go anybody
no they don't caramel apple and caramela
it's the worst thing that you could ever
buy and for your mouth I don't even like
apples but I'll bite into a camera
you take a bite at an entire caramel
skin pulls off
I'll tell you right out there or not let
me let me let me actually I don't like
caramela
I don't like caramel apples I do think
they suck but I'm not but that doesn't
kill caramel for me can you do me a
favor can you Google where there's
original is that a caramel based or this
original where there's original was it
toffee based it's toffee
like the Gobot it is a nougat and
caramel mix isn't it yeah right yeah
what is toffee oh look at this Werther's
was a laxative originally
sugar-free candy product Oh it's
sugar-free word this original no they
have to find a laxative warning printed
on me use Google
Voice originals and the first question
the most asked questions go down that
comes up is why are were these Originals
so good but can connect can you tell me
what's in there blending together is
every caramel every caramel crafted so
it's caramel based word is Originals bro
they suck
were these Originals South you can't be
are you insane
right now you came in here and I had a
candy bar
it was this is his only argument if you
came in here
all of these
movies
and before you get to it
popcorn before you even say it caramel
popcorn your popcorn Cracker Jacks in
this corner here Cracker Jack's in an
episode you Dopey [ __ ] Cracker Jacks
Cracker Jacks in here Cracker Jacks is
up in here yeah
they give me fun toys
that's true that's also true uh baseball
score the question
answer the question if you walked in
here and there was Ebola where there's
Originals individually wrapped would you
not pop one in your mouth no I wouldn't
you're foolish I would not I would you
like Karen
caramel or this original well then you
need to go to the doctor and have an
evaluation you know what I call it it is
worthless Originals
I hope they're not watching they suck I
hope they're not watching candy suck and
you know it let's take let's I don't I
love women out of a chocolate that you
love let's take one element out of a
chocolate combo thing that you love and
make it rock hard and then a choking hat
yeah it's a joke there's your words
like the original is there a
non-original workers no yeah where
there's a from a German candy maker he
hung his hat on it what do you mean yeah
that was the big candy that came out of
Germany it was a German Germany but why
is it the original because it's where
there's Originals people copied it so
they did were there what's his name were
their honkovich or something it's some
weird right boy Germany based in Berlin
Germany right where there's why do you
know this about Warriors
it was a caramel hard candy later
variants included
Chevy toffees a chocolate and a soft
waxy form which melts his mouth a
variant with chocolate fillings also
available as well as three sugarless
variants the original butterscotch
flavor yeah but oh I saw the
butterscotch too much I almost died on a
butterscotch I almost yeah I went to the
doctor's office when I was little
he had a bowl of candy let a child take
it I choked a woman I was choking yep my
mother goes oh my God he's choking legit
choking and it was like five people in
the office though nurses behind the desk
just looked at me and froze didn't do
anything a woman a big Burly woman stood
up grabbed me by both ankles her hands
to my ankles her hands the first time
she touched his hand to ankle she then
pulled my ankles up and she swooped me
just from a standing position upside
down and she shook me like I was a
cartoon
yes and you've been through the trauma
oh I was a child childhood trauma is
what ruins things
marshmallow because of childhood trauma
what happened in 1986 I watched the I
watched the movie the stuff I love the
movie the movie the stuff I never heard
of it yeah it's a film about I thought
you were just pulling my leg you've seen
the stuff it's a it's a knock-off
version of The Blob speaking of
non-original version and it's the stuff
yeah it's yeah it's about a a superfood
that they put out and there's a scene
where it goes into a guy's mouth it's
right on the right on the cover there
well you can see he's about to throw up
so I had to stay away from marshmallow
because I thought I Associated
Marshmallow with the stuff it looked
like marshmallow oh who's that kid I
know that kid see look at that who's
that kid right there not not him what
the [ __ ] is this movie it's a horror
movie like I said like this this is
unbelievable
yeah it comes out it's like the blob
yeah can you ask can you tell me
something that kid the the older brother
oh my god I've never I've never heard of
this in my marriage because it ruined me
it's a very directed by uh oh yes
use that image that's what I that's what
I thought every time I popped a
marshmallow in my mouth I saw Kitty
marshmallow 1986. what's wrong Larry
Cohen correct I think that's it's all a
mouthful is the kid yeah Larry Cohen no
no Larry Cohen's a great cult director
he also directed cue the wing serpent
Scott Bloom uh who is Scott Bloom
directed uh I believe return to Salem's
Lot he directed uh Larry Larry Cohen go
to Larry Cohen hold on I'm doing
something here Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I'm looking something up bro the stuff
ruined me I want to see what that who
would I get I knew that kid from
something no he's the kid from Smoking
Aces no no that's not it bro no he was
in John Q he was just no no
boss it's who's the boss the boss I
remember that he was in double dump the
episode double dump from who's the boss
on paper that's not a good name sir you
don't know I remember that kid yeah Rock
of Ages go to Larry Cohen's IMDb I want
to give a shout out to larcom Fan yeah
it's alive the it's a live Trilogy oh
the ambulance oh Mania cop of course
yeah Larry Cohen's is a g in the horror
world yeah the stuff around me for that
and the caramels I couldn't eat because
of my Orthodontics
I've for five years I wore Orthodontics
corrective uh braces five years they're
called Orthodontics I guess so aren't
they braces yeah I mean on the street
wait on the orthodontics is a is a word
I believe so like things of the
orthodontics
my Pediatrics is a part of pediatrician
Orthodontics I would say Orthodontics
now Joe you yeah just to Circle back to
the battle you hate both of these Foods
I hate both of these foods which
Orthodox what is the what is the hardest
insult you could throw at both caramel
and marshmallow I want you to give your
heart Essence well the the first the
first and foremost we already touched on
was texture they both leave you uh used
and abused like you are done when you've
touched either okay the stickiness of
both is gross and then also they're both
a chore to eat but give what I'm asking
for is say caramel dot dot dot
marshmallow dot dot I want to hear your
harshest critique of both in
individually not their shared dislikable
qualities for me marshmallow it's
texture I don't trust a marshmallow it's
you don't know the form it's had I don't
know where it's been I don't know like
flesh yeah yeah all right and caramel
it's going to be stickiness okay okay it
feels like you know Willy Wonka's load
[Music]
to me it's just amazing generally
generally
if I'd imagine yeah so but but what do
you I mean that would be amazing what do
you hate about the flavor of
re-ejaculated the flavoring I mean well
you know honestly if someone told me
that guy over there his name is Will
Wonka he ejaculates caramel I'd be like
I need I need to see it possibly taste
it
my friend Willie wonks yeah he bust
camera well you gotta taste this guy
yeah you gotta taste this guy's wand get
my boy
walk on him uh I I would probably I
would probably say for both of them I
you never can't I in their purest form
they're boring they need to be jazzed up
and presented with friends in a s'more
marshmallow for sure right honestly when
you're done chewing a marshmallow you
swallow it was it really a good ride it
is it's not a total taste but hold on a
second let me this is important we'll go
down on this list this is important to
point out
marshmallows in and of themselves are
fine caramel in and of itself is fine
but nobody's eating these things solo
you're just not but they're both
presented that way well but but they're
but but you you know where you're
playing
people are reading them stop it
I'll take marshmallows in a hot
chocolate let me finish my point though
yeah where you're finding marshmallows
and caramel in the grocery store in the
[ __ ] baking they're in the
ingredients aisle exactly exactly it's
like buying chocolate chips and going oh
you eat chocolate no there was a bowl of
chocolate chips here you would eat yeah
yeah exactly you're finding caramel in
the candy aisle well you know what
you're finding oh you're not caramels
yeah no you're nuts yeah you find a bag
of Brats you can find a bricks yeah or
you're finding like you you're certainly
off but still but it's a bottom shelf
what about what about down by your shoes
what about the caramel with that like
white stuff in the middle caramel with
the white stuff in the middle that's
disgusting
the Sun goes on it's like a Halloween
[Music]
I always thought it might be disgusting
and I had it when I was like Pleasant um
I will say this I will say this most
excuse me most
um
of the time these two things are are
part of a greater good they're enhancers
they're enhancers yes I agree and I will
say when it comes to enhancers
marshmallow is running the [ __ ] is is
ruling the roost I you have never had
something you're not with caramel in it
that kicks it up the way marshmallow
picks something else
has diarrhea shooting out of his mouth
as an enhancer you cannot touch caramel
because Marsh there's no such thing as a
marshmallow drizzle caramel drizzle
[ __ ] that's fancy [ __ ] all over
things
on top of the sweet potatoes at
Thanksgiving I'm a full marshmallow you
dumb [ __ ] that's what I'm saying
right
no but not like a caramel drizzle a
caramel drizzle a [ __ ] Chef you got
[ __ ] Gordon Ramsay
stand up so I can hear you when you're
talking out of your [ __ ] because it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] you do this weekly with
this dumb piece of [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's all functioning idiot does he
hang his [ __ ] helmet at the door
before he walks in here because I swear
to God I [ __ ] what time does your
ride get here I can't [ __ ] believe
you put yourself through this he's a
[ __ ] I swear to God is he battery
operated he needs to be [ __ ] rebooted
he needs to be rebooted because there's
something [ __ ] wrong with your dumb
Friends Jesus Christ taste buds oh like
[ __ ] taste done he's got no [ __ ]
tasting nothing Jesus Christ
hold on I'm sorry what were you saying
I love you Joey yeah no that's go [ __ ]
yourself
that's that's
all three Clips right there
that's all three clips
oh why are you so offended by the
enhance your voicemail I'm offended I'm
offended that you think they could be
they could be in the same conversation
as karma
was you summed up my feelings over 100
episodes
everything I think you feel every week
you just summed it up for me like you
know that Sketcher key and peel Where
Keegan Michael Key plays the inner
monologue of Barack Obama you just said
with me with him my stuff my stomach
actually hurts that was rage
it was truly amazing we're at my expense
and I'm saying that okay it was amazing
which one is you like caramel no I'm
marshmallow oh can I take that all back
but hold on I'm saying though I'm saying
I I I I I get your point I get your
point that the caramel drizzle and [ __ ]
marshmallows kick up cereal whatever a
s'more you know I don't like him without
that [ __ ] marshmallow I agree and you
know it sweet potato casserole we talked
about the mushrooms or marshmallows
right all right hot chocolate with a
marshmallow roasting marshmallows
honestly connectivity I get all what
you're saying I'm saying marshmallows
kicked the situation I'm significant I
am saying that more so than Caroline
marshmallows are awesome excited about a
caramel enhancement listen you don't get
excited when my cheesecake comes out of
the kitchen
I like cheesecake enough to [ __ ] eat
the caramel with it so [ __ ] it don't
worry about it because sometimes you
look at it it's like when the friend has
you know when the girl's got a friend
that's okay you're still talking about
them but listen here's what I'm saying
what I'm saying is nobody knows how to
say caramel it's caramel caramel [ __ ]
that's the first thing right but also
[ __ ] [ __ ] the thing I'm gonna say
is listen marshmallow is not pronounced
marshmallow it's marshmallow nobody's
always even had to say these dumb things
that you [ __ ] people like but I'm
saying you're telling me you're telling
me
hear me the [ __ ] up go I will give you
I've seen you two things I say to a
group of people two things at a dinner
party got it folks
cake we got cheesecake but we've added a
caramel drizzle or folks we're gonna
roast some marshmallows what gets people
more excited your dumb [ __ ] drizzle
your dumb [ __ ] drizzle or marshmallow
I'm sorry I'm sorry do we want to do an
apple or an orange in this [ __ ] thing
all right do you want to go do you want
to go to Las Vegas or you want to come
to my aunt's funeral you might as well
ask me those two things because you're
giving me an activity roast a
marshmallow versus eat this nobody gets
excited about the caramel enhancements
Rocio marshmallow is an experience an
experience okay okay hey guys I got a
new cereal that's got marshmallows in it
or I got a cheesecake with a caramel
drizzle I'm more excited about the
cereal with the marshmallows that's
because you're that's because you're an
idiot and you like breakfast over
dessert to you no no no no no no I
didn't say that did I [ __ ] say that
well would you just compare a breakfast
and a dessert did I say that I'm sorry
I'm interpreting your dog words that are
coming out of your stupid mouth I just
want to know for the record he's
supposed to be a mediator you've turned
me yeah this is thank you so much it's
impossible it's impossible
[Music]
two weeks ago because he got attacked so
hard for singing on the podcast that's
how hard everybody
I'm the [ __ ] yo you [ __ ]
I didn't turn off comments what are you
talking about people wrote to me and
said Sal turned off
never turned off comments that's that's
completely that's a lie most people
trying to make you feel better
foreign
I don't give a [ __ ] I can't believe
people didn't like your singing I know
it was a horror show I disagree I think
so no no he doesn't have a good voice
okay the bit
anyway my point is this you understand
you were supposed to come in to be a
moderator and he can't even
hold the course there because yes
because you talk so much [ __ ] YouTube
you two are in [ __ ] kahoots you've
been at Cahoots for years all right you
had your [ __ ] precious TV show
together yeah yeah you're in [ __ ]
this is what you got to resort to uh
you made Millions with it oh yeah okay
do anything now that has to do with
anything right now pimp I just said
while I was yelling over Sal you're
gonna have to bleep that I don't want to
get lost in the battle
[Laughter]
good good
your whole [ __ ] life I'm surprised
he's turning on me turning on you he's
here to be a mediator and a moderator an
in-between guy he doesn't like either
yeah look what happened because nobody
with a sandwich that's like Trump
bringing in uh Steve Bannon and going
this guy's Mutual
also it's like that and probably
something like McDonald's I would say if
Sal said something as dumb as you did I
would give him the same he yelled at me
like that before multiple times in life
I know okay we're joking here
always do this I'm so glad we're joking
too [ __ ] I know but uh
you don't quite understand the craft in
the way I do
I've done well with the craft of yelling
my friend
delusional here's delusional here's the
point I I wait Queen Elizabeth died
choked on the werthers
she died that's what she was oh she died
she's dead now or rip oh like in the
like the last time like right now yeah
right now oh wow holy [ __ ] 96 well I
mean sweet who's successful
Charles now right but Charles is dead
it's not they have to name a new Queen
no no what do you mean no successor it
says Prince Charles is alive yeah Prince
Diana Princess Diana so Prince Charles
now is King Charles talking about what
prince prince comes King right is that
how that works that was the running joke
all the time was like Prince Charles is
gonna be he's gonna die before he
becomes a king he's like in his 70s
right wait oh really so there's just not
a new Queen now there's nothing by the
hierarchy it's our first now there's no
Queen no there's no no his wife becomes
a queen
his wife becomes a queen yeah
yeah it's like an in-law well who's her
husband he's dead the king who's her
husband yeah she doesn't have a husband
yeah the king died was who he was he who
was he who was the king she's 93 so it's
like King Richard who was the king I'm
sorry but I don't I don't I don't know I
can't call it up I don't uh I don't know
I believe it was King Ralph they made a
movie about it starring John Goodman
no kingroth
the movie was Wreck-It Ralph remember
the John Goodman movie King Ralph was
genre that was her husband Prince Philip
oh he was a prince the queen married a
prince
the king
his name was Ralph or something I don't
I don't recall yeah the only thing
marshmallows are good for is plugging my
ears to block out the shrill screams of
Joe when he loses an argument thank you
Matt all right we're going to the phones
Joe we go where are we babe where are we
babe
all right we can't even agree on how to
pronounce caramel and now we're supposed
to say it's better than marshmallow we
need a better we need to do better as a
society
uh uh I agree with the with the
pronunciations caramel caramel I don't
like it it honestly if I've ever been
around a friend or anyone that's ever
good
secretly go got Karma caramel caramel
macchiato caramel macchiato it says
c-a-r-a and yeah hey can you go to the
Wiki page and hit pronunciation yeah
let's let's get it right off of the
phones as soon as we go to them
caramel
caramel caramel
so it's not caramel caramel but look
wait there's a there is it says caramel
but then it also says caramel there yeah
it's both
well it's spelled caramel
I I think it's spelled both ways now
Oh the marshmallow voice is sexier see
she doesn't she it is she does say
mellow look m-e-l-o yeah
why is it pronounced mellow it's I don't
know okay well one is a DJ
that is true
right yeah caramel all the way sweet and
chewy it makes everything more delicious
marshmallows are just boring and slimy
both are sticky but one is also creamy
caramel wins don't make me choose my
teeth say neither good point yeah try
roasting caramel don't worry I'll wait
good point caramel's Timeless
marshmallows are only good for s'mores
and for baiting for skunk that's right I
didn't know that Adam all animals love
marshmallow really what about animals
marshmallow they do it in a lot of
female
marshmallows like a full marshmallow and
throw at somebody that's fun it is
psycho caramel getting all stuck in your
teak it's a fun little game getting it
out nothing better that's the worst
aspect of carrots that's the worst I
don't like it but I kind of I think it's
almost like what she's talking about
it's almost like a journey almost like
um uh uh what's that nut that you gotta
open on the shell pecan no pecan you
know you gotta bite the shell Pistachio
Pistachio yeah something like that it's
like literally we'll not buy ice cream
if it has caramel in it like when I go
to the Ben and Jerry aisle
and I'm like let me try when we got
flavors wise this week yeah I will not
buy it if it is well see that's that's
odd for me because that's actually your
biggest argument but one of your biggest
arguments you don't like the stickiness
of it the cold makes it not sticky so
it's more magical I agree but I don't
like but you know what here's here's
what's funny and I'll discredit myself I
also will not buy ice cream in those
marshmallows in it yeah not many do
marshmallows are just puffy version of
Sweetness in that in the way Bart
Chrysler is a puffy
Chrysler God I mean Ray Ray I'm gonna
take two seconds to check your spelling
no you Joe
that's that's the point people call him
burnt Chrysler and every other variation
of his name except his name why it's an
ongoing gag I really don't know okay all
right I'm sorry Ray Ray
marshmallows
my hat in hand ray ray
uh you really retracted quickly too that
whiskey must be kicking in
yeah I'm still flying from yesterday uh
caramel is a creamy delicious additive
where marshmallows make me want to nose
dive into the nearest source of
petroleum jelly in which I could drown I
don't understand that Joe stop with the
marshmallow and the weenie dogs you
don't stand a chance to caramel notice
they they knew you had marshmallow yeah
transverse trash
but marshmallows are only good to throw
in a fire Sal has to be marshmallows
because he's soft and fluffy caramel no
doubt either the gooey marshmallows are
the 98 Geo Metro Suites caramel's more
like a BMW caramel feels better on my
dentures what are you nuts by themselves
by themselves caramel all day with other
things marshmallow okay there's a well
marshmallows had a has it has had a uh
pop culture impact in a way the safe off
Marshmallow Man right I forgot so you
have that as well where there's nothing
there's nothing iconic about a caramel
is that that's a great Point
have a picture Joe read it so that the
viewer can understand Joe you idiot
that's good that's good podcasting you
blame me for going off the phones to to
do something like
no the correct pronunciation of camera
was Karma which is going to be
interesting and you go it's going to be
something
because this is a good one brother
you dead I am now have you had your
phone I'm having fun feeling a big man
now in front of your buddy I do
I could totally picture Joe standing in
a ditch eating marshmallows run out of
the bag not even as a kid I could see
him doing it now on a red app Tuesday
afternoon that's our winning comp
comment uh tweets uh follow Maya at Maya
Marie with two e's nine nine at
m-a-y-a-m-a-r-i-e-e marshmallow is a
basically dried up snowman bowls but I
would cover Sal and caramel drizzle
hashtag taste to your buddies wow all
right let's go oh snowballs too which I
have defended on the show and I love
it's a treat uh snowball we got snowball
7 600 votes
uh I have a feeling caramel's gonna win
I don't know I really I truly
truly tell I really cannot oh wait plugs
before we
before we do the uh guys uh merch is up
at the store you can get it on my
website or Joe savvalcano comedy.com
with JoJo rosainfo.com uh the merch once
that merch is sold out which is headed
there uh you can't get it anymore we're
not gonna remake anything that we have
uh we might make some new new patterns
but this is this first run will be gone
check that out uh we'll we'll insert our
tour dates up top but we're both on tour
and do me a favor you want a free way to
support the Pod do us a favor and just
uh follow us on Spotify uh follow us on
subscribe on subscribe on YouTube
channel on YouTube and on iTunes rate it
it could take five seconds for you and
it would really help us we'd really
appreciate it yes Joe plucks
you got you got your tour right now you
have a podcast you got my tour yeah do
you want me to do it
I'm touring throughout the end of the
year all my tour dates are announced so
joegattoofficial.com I'm coming all over
uh the United States uh the second one
is uh my podcast with Steve Byrne who we
spoke of we love two Cool Moms podcast
that's available and If you just go to
Instagram Joe underscore ghetto it's got
a link link that's got everything on
there cuckoo rob it yeah all right
Humble Pie
whoever wins excuse me has to say I
still love you
and then wow that's nice too that's a
nice touch you guys do yeah so let's get
this drum roll right here pimpy get the
uh get the statistics in the lower right
hand corner
didn't think it would be like that
didn't think it would be that honestly I
thought it would be I thought it would
be closer that's a bit of a trouncing
yeah
74.9 goes to caramel with 25.1 percent
to marshmallows I disagree also also we
always say this and we never do it but
I'd love to know I'd love to be keeping
tally of the second season you've never
paid the piper for the first season
I don't know get off your lazy ass and
do it then well Italian comes from our
wonderful you can look it up you could
look it up it would take you three
minutes I don't know instead of [ __ ]
farming it out to some [ __ ] fan for
free no no that might be nice and an
easy way for us to keep track if we get
what the most currency is looking at the
uh looking at the videos that we have a
full record of like yeah that's that's
the way to do it um I'm sorry I'll just
make fun of you for not doing good
podcasting when you were trying to read
stuff and now he's going to give
instructionals about how he's doing this
for me
the big famous guy wants it done for him
get get up your [ __ ] ass I remember
when you used to have grinding yourself
that Jack Daniels is almost gone
so I had one
to get [ __ ]
um big sip
I can quit any time
oh man she's still bleeding a nice idea
would be um just get like let's say this
episode whatever get let's get what the
what the number is and then put it at
the end with the Humble Pie put it on
screen or just in the comments and then
once we know what it is you'll always be
able to know the next one so we could
just always keep track I think it means
something I like to tally it okay well
what's the punishment what are we gonna
do well that's season one I I I we're
still waiting you said something else
all kinds of suggestions didn't you
pitch didn't we agree on something
scorpion we'd had 100 ideas we had no we
had the fans send ideas in did we ever
check them no we have to review them
sorry I'm just so busy let's review them
yeah but you don't got to do something
like that's really off-brand for him
that's fun like he's got to like you
know go into like enjoy his day not
exactly I was gonna say that like smile
all day yeah like you just be happy for
a day and see how his how his body
rejects it and like an hour 18 of him
having to smile that would be
unbelievable yeah the problem is the
problem is some of the suggestions are
too much from the from the show that you
guys of course yeah it's like Joe should
have to get a tattoo you know what I
mean so we don't want to do that some of
the suggestions are too like where I'm
just like I'm not doing that of course
harming my body no no not with the
tattoo I mean it'll be like drink this
and see you don't do that over there I'm
like I'm not doing that but I will do
the thing we were gonna do was we were
gonna the loser of the first season
which is now me had to eat a bag of what
was it sugar-free gummy bears yeah and
because she made you [ __ ] your brains
out but then they discontinued uh but
like something I think you should do no
I think I just I humbly disagree I think
you should like we should dress you up
when you should go to a children's
hospital for a day and go and like smart
with people I would love to do that
right that would be a joyfulness
no I think like that I think you'd have
okay
that's great you're gonna dress up as
Ronald [ __ ] McDonald's there you go
McDonald's
shoes and do your face up and we're
gonna go walk the street yes
[Music]
oh I think he bartends a shift to Joey
Rosa
oh it's great
so I'm glad it was me
with Bobby Lee sitting here what's up
Miss Ronald McDonald I will go into
public with you
that's my punishment that is so funny
let's culminate it one one hour behind
the bar yeah
yeah come on Joe yeah that's fun
all right for the taste buds fans I will
bartend at Joy roses for one hour
dresses Ronald McDonald that's it I love
it that's what I'm doing great that's
the end of it great because balloons be
involved no no you have to be there but
let's go on the street for like a little
bit and hear that balloon yeah
like a promotional thing
I'll do it in front of the bar
we gotta get one of the Joey roses signs
and he goes and Spins it please let me
know when this is
[Music]
I'm handing out balloons in front of the
bar and then I'm bartending for an hour
there is an end and we take a picture of
you and that becomes your new social
media like Avatar
no per day why not why because I don't
want to eat it's a year of loss hence
punishment
right that's enough and then it becomes
your avatar why not now sorry if you
don't like comedy sorry he doesn't like
comedy oh yeah that's just my problem do
it get the most out of it milked a bit
why would you make your avatar it's
funny
I'm not making my avatar me dresses a
[ __ ] clown guys right to the podcast
on Instagram or Twitter and put get
ready
right through your fingers [ __ ] bleed
like this one I'm not doing it I will
dress up in the middle inside the street
and bartend at the bar and all the fans
can come to the bar for that hour that
I'm barking that's fun that's fair
please let me know when it is please let
me know when this is happening I would
love to come join you for a beverage do
you serve ginger ale at your establish
yes we do right yeah we do oh those are
the clown died too right both of the
clown also died
I would turn it all in to make it the
album cover of your next uh next session
no this is this is perfect for you how
about your music album huh no guys it's
gone too far away
it's not too far but this is it this is
what he does he gets a bit and he thinks
it's funny and he runs with it you're
telling man
on that note
I still love you baby
I still love you you guys are both okay
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste but